yeah the game we have another Nicholas
Sparks adaptation the author of various
adaptations that have turned into movies
like message in a bottle a walk to
remember the notebook Nights in Rodanthe
Dear John the last song and now this
thing the lucky one is directed by Scott
Hicks and stars Zac Efron Taylor
Schilling Blythe Danner and some other
people too
oh I can actually say with complete
confidence in my sexuality that I have
seen each previous film mentioned every
single one of them I am a man and what
I'm going to learn is that Nicholas
Sparks movies have a checklist as I like
to call it a literal checklist of
Nicholas Sparks cliches and this one
fits the bill perfectly
number one a quiet mysterious stoic man
perhaps a former soldier number to a
woman who complains endlessly about her
romantic frustrations while all the
while has literally the perfect man
right in front of her number three a
location that resembles a vacation like
getaway examples could be a mysterious
forest or a beautiful beach and finally
a tragedy that links all of the
characters together preferably a death
in the family in the past or soon-to-be
future and the lucky one conforms the
Nicholas Sparks checklist 100% Zac Efron
plays a mysterious stoic
quiet soldier who finds a picture of a
woman in the war in this picture he
bends over and just so happens he misses
a giant blast that could have killed him
because he found this picture he comes
back from the war what does he do he
decides to find out who this woman is
even though he has absolutely zero
information about her because he
believes that she brings him luck and
that he was destined to meet her the
film quickly glosses over a montage
where he somehow figures out where this
girl is what literally no information
except for the fact that there is a
lighthouse in the back of her photo he
figures out where that lighthouse is
somehow and walks from Colorado to
Louisiana with his dog let me repeat
that he walks from Colorado to Louisiana
with his dog and zero luggage I looked
this up okay that's over 1,000 miles and
this film expects us to be okay with the
fact that he literally walked over 1,000
miles with no luggage no pairs of
clothes
and a German Shepherd arrives at the dog
kennel where this woman magically works
that he magically found completely
unscathed no dirt no sweat nothing and
we're supposed to believe this and this
dog kennel in her house happens to be in
the middle of this beautiful forest
sanctuary perfect for a Nicholas Sparks
location and she happens to be a
romantically frustrated woman who
recently had a tragedy in her life that
we will soon learn links these
characters together it will blossom in a
wonderful romance that will more than
likely end in some sort of Tears sadness
and embrace now I'm being harder on this
movie than I normally would and I'll
tell you why it's because I'm getting
tired of the fact that all these
Nicholas Sparks movies have the exact
same plots I mean it's literally like he
takes a checklist adds different
locations and mixes them around and okay
here's my next book you know it's crazy
they are all the exact same Zac Efron is
a likeable actor I've liked him in the
past but here you just you just conforms
to this script that is just so cliched
and predictable you know exactly where
this movie is going down to the montage
of sadness that I have noticed as in
Sony different romantic films where at
some point in the movie characters will
have a giant argument truths will come
out and they will hate each other for
about a 10 to 15 minute span and more
than likely it'll be some form of
montage with like a pop song or
something in the background and of
course we get that here the acting in
the movie is not terrible the directing
in the movie is not terrible the film
looks nice it's produced well it's just
that I'm so sick of seeing this exact
same story over and over again the way
this film ends it's like kind of shoving
this relationship down your throat and
it makes you want to just feel like yes
I feel so of lifted now but know you've
been cold buy this movie I'm just tired
of seeing the same movie over and over
again the lucky one is just not a good
film it's a competently made film it's a
good looking and has some good
performances but it's just the story is
so run-of-the-mill we've seen it a
thousand times and that's why I'm gonna
get the lucky one a d-plus it's like
since it's called the lucky one that
we're just supposed to like accept the
fact that he having to walk a thousand
miles over a Colorado the Louisiana
found this girl she happens to be there
she's working in this beautiful dog
kennel he's good with dogs and all this
stuff just works because it's called The
Lucky One we're supposed to accept the
fact that all these impossible
coincidences happen no not me
as always guys if you like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and gets
stuckman eyes